welcome to the show donald trump and joe
biden
had their first debate last night and
there was great interest in it we had 64
000 people watch live with me on our
streams and i want to go through what
happened
and i have really been struggling with
how to summarize
such an insane event and this analogy
came up the last time
i was on with joe rogan in general about
the trump presidency
and sometimes you know our instinct is
to analyze
things with the frameworks we're
accustomed to and
i can't really analyze yesterday's
debate with the frameworks we're
accustomed to because it was completely
insane it was the analogy i made to joe
rogan
if he's doing ufc commentary and one
of the fighters sets the other fighter
on fire
and you say that's an aggressive tactic
it's like no that doesn't even come
close to encompassing the absurdity
of what we're dealing with and i even
woke up briefly in the middle of the
night to have a sip of water
and i thought how do i explain what
happened last night so
i'm going to try we'll do it in pieces
and hopefully by the end we'll have
sort of an understanding of what the
hell went on last night and and maybe
more importantly its broader meaning in
the election and in the united states
now the top line is
i've never seen a debate this bad that
can mean a lot of different things so
i'll clarify but i've been watching
presidential debates since 1996
when i was a mere lad of 12. i've never
seen a debate devolve into being so
worthless as what donald trump was able
to turn last night's
last night's debate into i asked some
people who are older
and have been watching debates longer
they don't remember any debate
turning into as much of a circus as what
we saw last night
so i think we can say with with
certainty that last night was the worst
debate in the history of presidential
debates
since they've been recorded and
broadcast either via audio or video
and my guess is given what we know about
prior debates earlier in american
history that last night was
the worst debate of any debate we've
seen in presidential campaigns
now to get us into the conversation
let's discuss it in terms of biden
trump and the moderator chris wallace
joe biden did okay
now i'm not going to lie to you and say
biden just did great and he was dynamic
and energetic and all of this stuff
there's no question that joe biden was
stumbling quite a bit
it was not his stutter that was the
problem it was that he seemed to
struggle
sort of sequentially laying out his
views on some issues but he did okay
he didn't collapse as many trumpists
were hoping biden had four or five
good answers his closing was arguably
his best moment about voting which we
will get to
he had two or three zingers which i mean
it sucks that
that's even something that we look at
but if you were hoping for some zingers
he had a few donald trump made the
debate impossible
so donald we could argue like if you use
a chess analogy
joe biden had some good moves and he had
some inaccuracies
no blunders donald trump flipped the
board over
and threw the pieces into the trash and
he would not shut up he interrupted what
must have been 50 times
during joe biden's time to speak trump
would just
talk over him and insult him trump went
after joe biden's son for having a drug
problem
trump said joe biden wasn't smart he
made fun of him for the college that he
went to
trump did not substantively discuss a
single issue
and then there was the moderator chris
wallace now there are people saying
chris wallace did well given the
circumstances
there are others saying chris wallace
did poorly what we can't deny
is that chris wallace did not have
control over the debate chris wallace
was begging and pleading with donald
trump to stop interrupting joe biden
trump wouldn't listen chris wallace had
no ability to cut the mic of the
candidates
in order for him to have that both
candidates would have to agree to it i
can't imagine trump would ever agree to
that
so chris wallace as well intentioned as
he might have been was helpless to stop
donald trump
so what i can say is that wallace wasn't
equipped to take control of the debate
you can say well he wasn't given the
equipment
because the candidates decided there was
no mute button that wallace would have
access to
whatever he did as well as he could you
can say but he didn't take
control of it trump controlled it now in
terms of the level of discourse
that trump forced upon us it couldn't
have been
lower or more base or more embarrassing
complete inability to discuss any policy
in detail
facts and dignity did not matter trump
refused to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups and
actually this is the first clip we'll
look at trump
activated the militia groups by very
coyly saying
they should stand by stand
by take a look at this clip but are you
willing tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not add to the violence in a number
of these cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you doing what are you saying i'm
willing to do anything i want to see
peace
sir say it do it say it do you want to
call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white surprise
and write prophecy boys stand back and
stand by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what now this
of course standby is something very very
different
than stand down and all sorts of white
nationalists and militia types
immediately tweeting that that was a
call from trump for them to be ready to
stand
by for the post-election period a
completely
ruinous moment for the discourse and for
the status
of the united states of america from the
debate so
now trump this is just one of a dozen
examples two dozen examples
trump just talking over biden not
allowing biden his time
like a petulant child be in that
option number one so you agree with me
with bernie sanders
far left on the manifesto that's because
you socialize medicine look hey
are you still not gonna listen to him
the fact of the matter is i beat bernie
sanders
not very much i beat him a whole hell of
a lot i'm here i'm here standing facing
you
would have left two days certainly you
would have lost every problem
now you might think david that sounded
like two clips that sounded like a clip
of joe biden talking
and a clip of donald trump talk talking
superimposed
no no that's how the debate went
throughout donald trump
i could play 12 clips like that for you
i could play 24 clips like that for you
i won't do it maybe the lowest moment of
the debate
was uh donald trump going after joe
biden's son
for having a drug problem i'm talking
about my son bo biden you're talking i
don't know
i don't know beau i know hunter hunter
got thrown hunter got thrown out of the
military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true
cocaine use and he didn't have a job
until you became vice president what do
you mean
he made a fortune in ukraine in china in
moscow that is simply various
other places can you imagine going after
it's not even biden but going after
biden
because biden's son had a drug
problem this is a health issue when
trump
brings up joe biden's son's drug problem
it's like making fun of someone because
your kid has diabetes
it's like ridiculing someone because
your kid has
cancer that's what we're talking about
here
uh disgusting i mean just a complete
debasement of what at some point in
american history were substantive
policy discussions some good biden
moments
here while trump is repeating this idea
that biden will end the suburbs this
ridiculous idea biden says trump
wouldn't know a suburb unless he took a
wrong turn
into one michael left supporters and
once he does that it's over with but
if he ever got to run this country and
they ran it the way he would want to run
it
we would have our suburbs would be gone
by the way
our suburbs would be gone and you would
see problems like
he wouldn't know a suburb unless he took
a wrong turn oh i know celebrities
when biden did land zingers trump really
wasn't able to
to reply which was interesting often uh
biden would just say
no you no you i'm sorry trump would say
no you know you
and and did not the point is when biden
was
able to put together a quick retort
trump actually didn't do so well biden
at one point calling trump a clown
they've you've already fired most of
them because they did a good job some
people don't know but here's it
with you wait a minute you get the final
word well it's hard to get any word in
with this clown
excuse me this hey let me just say no no
no so as you can see
it's a very low level of conversation
there hilariously there were some
trumpists
who focused on that moment to claim that
it was biden who was being indecorous
during the debate because he used the
word clown about donald trump
you're sort of missing the forest for
the trees if that's your takeaway and
then one more moment
joe biden saying that donald trump is
the worst president
that the country has ever had when
donald trump tried to interrupt joe
biden
tax code that made him
put him in a position that he pays less
tax than a schoolteacher
makes on the money a school teacher
makes is because
of him take he says he's smart because
he can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're going to
eliminate those taxes
and make sure that we invest in the
people who in fact
need the help people out there need help
but why didn't you do it over
the last 25 years because you weren't
president because you weren't president
screwing things up
you were a senator you're the worst
president that america has ever had
let me just tell you joe i've done more
in in 47 months
i've done more than you've done in 47
years joe
now one of the things biden did do well
and i thought that this was a good
approach and biden actually did this
really well if you go back and watch the
2012 debate biden did with paul ryan um
something joe biden did really well was
to laugh off
some of the dumb things that trump said
authoritarians like trump
narcissists like trump they want people
to be mad people like trump want to
cause
anger because it's beneficial to them
and they think they can take advantage
of it and when biden would just laugh
trump didn't like it take a look at one
example people want their schools open
they don't want to be shut down they
don't want their estate shut down they
want their restaurants i look at new
york it's so sad what's happening in new
york it's almost like a ghost town
and i'm not sure it can ever recover
what they've done in new york
people want their places open they want
to get back to their lives people
they'll be careful but they want their
schools
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big ten
football
it was me and i'm very happy to do it
trump never once reacted well
when joe biden laughed and that to the
extent that it was a strategy i think
it's just biden's instinct
to the extent it was a strategy i think
it was good now
almost 10 minutes in now a bit more
substantively
here is joe biden pointing out why would
you trust trump on coronavirus trump did
his routine about how great everything
was on coronavirus
biden points out trump's been wrong
about everything and he actually raises
the topic of injecting bleach and trump
has
no way to respond other to say it was a
joke which we know it was not
before november 1st it could also be
generally available well we're going to
deliver it right away we have the
military all set up logistically they're
all set up
we have our military that delivers
soldiers and they can do two hundred
thousand a day
they're going to be this is the same man
it's all set up
by easter this would be gone away by the
warm weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle and by the way
maybe you could inject
some bleach in your arm and that would
take care of it this is the same way you
said sarcastic that was you know that i
would've said sarcasm so here's the deal
any of you who remember that incident
know it was not sarcasm
trump has demonstrated no ability to be
capable of sarcasm
trump can do nothing that was a good
moment for joe biden
check out this comparison now between
how trump answered will you pledge to
accept the election results
will you pledge to ask your supporters
for calm
in the aftermath of the election and
will you accept the results when they
are certified this was the last
sort of main topic in the debate and
we're going to go to trump's answer then
biden's answer
trump when asked doesn't say yes attacks
mail in voting
and says this is ominously not going to
end well what's going on take a look at
west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country
this is not there is no this is not
going to end well
here is trump again wildly bringing in
hillary clinton of trying to
coo donald trump saying they have obama
and biden's crimes on tape
which is out of this world zany and
if you are watching you will notice that
joe biden seems visibly perplexed by
what donald trump is talking about here
so when i listened to joe talking about
a transition there's been no transition
from when i won i won that election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
they came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won
and even before i won from the day i
came down the escalator with our first
lady
they were a disaster they were disgraced
to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan act against
general flynn
you better take a look at that because
we caught you in a sense and
president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free
transition as far as the ballots are
concerned it's a disaster
a solicited ballot okay
solicited is okay you're soliciting
you're asking they send it back you send
it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots
notice trump saying everything other
than i'll accept the results once they
are certified
talking about hillary when asked if he
will accept the results
this is an outrageous authoritarian this
is not about
populism or economic anxiety this is
authoritarianism
and then just a little more from trump
once again just horrible
trump telling his supporters go to the
polls
and watch now if you're not a poll
worker you can't just do this
you need to register as a poll worker if
you want to be at the polls
and trump again just trying to cause
chaos but it is so i
first for you sir finally for the for
the vice president i hope neither of you
will interrupt the other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you very much my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen
i am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem
in philadelphia they went in to watch
they were called poll watches a very
safe very nice thing
they were thrown out they weren't
allowed to watch yeah
trump complaining you can't just show up
and observe yeah well that's called
voter intimidation it's illegal in most
states i think hopefully all
whether it's enforced is another
question you can't just show up
now for contrast same question to joe
biden
and joe biden is able to give a one-word
answer and it's the only answer and the
answer is yes
i will accept the results when they are
certified and then trump still can't
contain himself
and interrupts and biden accurately
points out trump has no idea
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge not to declare victory until the
election is independently certified
yes and here's the deal recount the
balance as you pointed out
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened until
election day and if there's thousands of
ballots going to take time to do it and
by the way
our military they've been voting by
ballots
first since at the end of the civil war
in effect and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it not why is it for them
somehow not fraudulent it's the same
process
it's honest no one has established at
all
that there is fraud related to male
imbalance that somehow it's a fraudulent
process it's already been established
take a look at carol and maloney's
racism you had an opportunity
they have no idea why is president go
ahead he has no idea what he's talking
about here's the deal
the fact is i will accept it and he will
too you know why
because once the winner is declared
after all the all the ballots are
counted
all the votes are counted that'll be the
end of it that'll be the end of it
and if it's me in fact fine if it's not
me
i'll support the outcome and i'll be a
president not just for the
democrats i'll be a president for
democrats and republicans
and this guy i want to say honestly
gentlemen
will you say that's the end of this this
is the end of this debate this ballot
count
we're going to uh to be continued
as in more debates so trump continuing
to talk
over everyone as the debate actually
ends trump's still
talking this is what a uh
uh this this is what an authoritarian
lunatic sounds like
now could biden have done better yes
biden could have done better there were
missed opportunities for biden
uh to point out incredible hypocrisy
from donald trump for example
when trump's taxes came up donald trump
said both
that the story about his taxes is fake
news and actually he paid millions in
taxes
and trump said i'm smart and i take
advantage of the tax law biden could
have said
he's talking out of both sides of his
mouth he's not being honest is the story
fake
or is it accurate but you're happy about
it because you're smart enough not to
pay taxes
which is it it can't be both missed
opportunity
another instance of this happening was
trump mentioning that his supporters
were allowed to be poll workers
uh poll watchers in philadelphia that
was towards the end of the debate
biden missed the opportunity to say you
can't just show up
you can't that's not how it works it's
voter intimidation
meant to suppress the vote but this was
the whole point
trump made the debate impossible now in
the end when we say
biden did okay but sort of stumbled and
trump was a raving lunatic
what's the impact i don't believe
trump's strategy of causing chaos in the
debate serves him well
trump was so erratic and furious and
unhinged
that the contrast with joe biden's
stability could not have been more clear
now you can say well but joe biden
sounded
confused in some moments after reviewing
clips of the debate now with you and
preparing for the show earlier today my
big picture takeaway is that while
donald trump succeeded at preventing
substantive discussion
because he's unable to discuss policy
substantively
he made the event a laughingstock biden
comes away looking
stable in comparison and it's probably
bad for trump
trump's outlandish behavior also by the
way allowed biden to take some shots at
trump
without them seeming uncalled for
because compared to what trump did it
was small potatoes
uh and that there are people who want
that there are people who want zingers
and biden had a few so
the big picture right now is the polls
have biden up six on average
there is no clear winner here and donald
trump really debased himself
so i think it's bad for trump trump
needs to make
up six points biden did more than well
enough
not to lose a six-point lead then the
question becomes
are people's votes counted but we have
to come to some realizations based on
last night number one
if you still like trump as of last night
you're probably an authoritarian that's
something you have to think about you
know these claims of
well trump is a populist his message is
a message of populism
to appeal to economic anxiety there was
none of that last night
there was nothing populist about trump's
messages last night this was
authoritarianism plain and simple
and if you still follow them you're
either an authoritarian yourself
or you're indifferent to
authoritarianism either to own the libs
or for some other reason
but again my overall take is and i so i
know some people disagree with me
i don't think biden looked great i think
it was
okay but trump looked so chaotic
that biden looks good in comparison he
held his own
he landed a few shots my guess
is that the debate was so
debased that the ratings for the second
and third ones will be lower
i had you know we were joking about
mercy bands during my stream i said if
you
if you want to be banned as mercy to not
be able to watch my streams of the
future debates let us know
i think that trump making it unwatchable
will turn some people away from the
future debates but
i don't think it helps helps trump big
picture um
what else is important to say uh
what else did biden do well i mean biden
was more substantive
biden laid out some proposals in terms
of clean energy
coronavirus economics biden did call out
a lot of trump's bs
including things that trump denied when
there's video of it happening i think
that that was good
biden correctly linked trump to the
violence that's happening trump tries to
link biden to violence
biden's not the president i think biden
did a good job of saying this is true
this is trump's america right now
um and then i do think that on the last
issue which was was that of voter fraud
i think it was a disaster for trump
trump blurted out fraud fraud fraud
joe biden very clearly said we're going
to accept the results when they are
certified
and there's no evidence of voter fraud
vote by mail is the norm
in a lot of places it's gone absolutely
fine
so you got the sense that in the second
half of the debate
biden was better equipped to deal with
trump's constant interruptions and was
able to get some of those good hits in
overall the debate wasn't you know it
was it was a mess it was an s show as we
would say
and it was that 95 because of donald
trump
and 5 because of uh chris wallace we
still have to see how it goes the polls
have tightened and we're going to talk
about that after the break but in the
meantime
let me know what you made of the debate
i'm on twitter
deepakman if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into a doctor's office
right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me is a really perfect fit for
me and my medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video